Hey, I'm Jason. I'm Sean. I'm Will. They said do it quick, not like legal. Hi, I'm Jason. I'm Sean. I'm Will. And it's an all new smart list. Let's go. Let's go to all of this. Hey, do you guys ever grind your teeth? Because last night I had this pain from my jaw through my ear all the way up to my top of my head. You don't have a chew bar or a mouthpiece? You know what? That's a good idea though. I could take a chew toy from my dog. How about a bite plate? Well, you probably just use your cereal spoon. You just sleep with your cereal spoon in your mouth.
You know how much I love cereal. And I like to mix cereal. Every time he calls me, he has a bowl of cereal in his mouth. I know. And I make big industrial. I just finished off a nice big bowl of lentils. A big lentil soup. Gosh, that's delicious. Do you remember lentil soup? Yeah. What do you mean? I'm not in a fight with my body, so I eat healthy food, so I don't need to remember lentils. It was yesterday and a couple of days before that. Oh, man. Legumes. You really showed me. Yeah. Well, yeah. Your body will go into shock when you give it frosted flakes seven
days a week and then you give it some lentils off the same spoon. You guys, I'm going to fight with my body too. That's why I'm drinking juicy juice this morning. Why are you so angry at your colon? You had to infantilize it, right? Like you just needed to have like a little kitty name on it to make it. And Will, you had a Diet Coke there, did you? Yeah. Do you know the gang down at Diet Coke? Again, I keep asking if they've got a face man or just a pitch man or a voice man because I'm ready.
I don't think they advocate drinking it at 10.03 AM West Coast time. They do like these large glass bottles of just orange liquid that I have here, which is water and electrolytes. I love those. That's why I'm 67 years old. I look like this. And I love those bottles that look like you ripped them off of an Amish farm. You know what I mean? Just to keep it rustic in Beverly Hills. I know. God damn it. What a clown show.
Their style inside the fridge, which I think is going too far. But yeah, there's a lot. I've seen your, your wife, but by the way, it should be noted, your wife has excellent taste. She really does. In stuff, not in dudes. Oh, right. Oh, I feel like that's a shot at me. Maybe. Let me think about it. I'm, I'm, I'm guys. I'm super excited about our guest today. You know, it's not the biggest
guest we've had on, but still this person was really kind to say yes to me. And I've loved this person for a very long time. An incredible story. Actually, this person played Bobby Hopkins on the golden girls. One of my favorite characters. I'm one of my favorite sitcoms. And then get this didn't work for 20 years. And then out of nowhere wins an Oscar, right? What? We have an Oscar winner. Not since Roberto Bonini. Guys, it's George Clooney.
Hang on. Come on. George. What? Did I skip anything? Did I get that right? Well, I was a little hurt that I wasn't the biggest star that you've ever seen. No, no, no, he didn't say biggest star, biggest guest. And I think Kamala Harris, you would agree has got to be right near the top, sharing the pinnacle with, with Stacey Abrams, perhaps.
Yes, I would agree that I'm not, I'm not in that league. And maybe Paul McCartney, can, can he be above your, your altitude? Well, you know, what has he really done? This is good. This is really good. I, I, that was my attempt at being sarcastic, George. Can I say something? You know, I've been listening to this podcast. Do you like to call it? He has notes. He's got notes. I wanted to do this show. I wanted to do this show because I do really enjoy it. And I have
to say I enjoy it mostly because I feel as if the guest really doesn't, isn't involved at all in the show. No, it doesn't matter. You don't have to do anything. There's no pre-interview. It doesn't matter who it is. Sean doesn't even have questions. No, you talk about each other. And we don't let you do any talking.
And I enjoy it so much that I thought I'd just come on and just sit back. Yeah. Yeah. You make a really good point. And I want to get into that. But first, Sean. Yeah. What's up? So you don't have the bite plate. Exactly. You don't have the cereal spoon.
George. George, I'm so excited you're here hanging out with us. Yes. I'm so excited too. And thank you for taking the time. I know you're... It's fun to see you guys. It's a great delight. You know, Sean, you know, Jason and I, people will not know this. But Jason was a very big star of a show called Silver Spoons.
Yes. And we were at Gower Studio. I was doing the Facts of Life. It was like 1985 or 86, maybe. And I'd set up a little basketball court out in the back and Jason, young Jason, very young Jason, would come out and shoot some hoops. And we would shoot around back in the... Back in a long time ago. I had a nice mullet then. Oh, you did. You were trying to bite Stamos' style. You were going for your blackie look. Well, you know, he had it down, by the way. He did.
He looked good. So, George, so you knew Jason back then. He came and he played basketball. And then he kind of, you know, he has a long career in showbiz. And then he reaches new heights later in life. And were you just as shocked as anybody to see him find success? I knew there was something hurtful at the end of it. It was pretty surprising. You know, every once in a while, you know, we'd touch base. I'd see him at an event. And I kept thinking, first of all, I think I haven't seen you in a while. And then I would think that's about right.
You'd go, oh, that's why. Look at him bearing it to the walls. There's the reason. Everybody had shorted my stock and did very well. George, where are you right now, by the way? Because for some reason it's hard for my brain to accept that you live in Italy, because I prefer that you live in the same town that we do. So I can just come and go as I please. Well, I'm living in Boston as we speak. In fact, I'm looking out at the ocean right here. I'm doing, I'm directing a film in Boston right now with Ben Affleck and wonderful actors.
I'm so excited that you're doing more and more and more directing. Do you see that, not to get into a serious question, but do you have a sense of the ratio, how you'd love for it to go or not go? Is it all project related or? No, you know, I mean, how much are you, you're doing a lot now, right? I'd prefer to do it full time only because I'll bet like you, you, it's so complicated and challenging, more so than the acting. Maybe it's a more difficult job, I don't know, but you seem to be as comfortable with the acting as I am and was and you maybe want to take on a little bit more.
I think it's interesting. First of all, it is that, you know, at some point, particularly when you've done television, because when you're doing television, you're doing 22 hours a year of, you know, it's like doing 11 movies. So, you know, you're doing a lot of acting and it's fun to be involved. But in general, I, you know, about 25 years ago, I just started looking at thinking, I don't want to worry about what some casting director thinks of how I'm aging, you know, I'm going to be 60 this year and well, well, by the way, just well, not, not as well as I'd hope, but you know, the alternative is death. So I'll take it.
George, let me ask you this. I want to, so, so you mentioned television and I love the way that you kind of threw that out because up until kind of the nineties, up until when you were on ER, there was, there were television actors and there were film actors. And you know, there was kind of that divide did exist. And sometimes often people made the leap, but there was that sort of, there was a kind of a television actors were often frowned upon or looked down upon. Yeah, we were at the Golden Globes. It's called the television tier in the back. Right.
And when you get to move down to the front, you feel really privileged. Yeah, yeah. But you kind of, you threw that all away. You, you came off of ER, you went into film, you were instantly successful and did it in a way that kind of gave, I thought it was fucking rad and awesome and you don't delineate between any of it. Well, I was lucky in a way. You know, it is funny. You guys all know this, having done all of it, there is this, there's this weird pecking order that you learn the moment you get into acting into the industry where it's like the theater actors shit all over the film actors and the film actors shit all over the telly. It kind of was this, a lot
of that seems to have gone by the wayside. I think part of the streaming thing has helped in a way because there's really interesting films. Television really changed honestly with the Sopranos in terms of the kind of things you could do. You could, you know, there could be nudity and foul language and things that would, I think it's been a kind of process. Clint Eastwood came out of television. Well, you bring up a good point. If my memory is working right. I feel like you made a big declaration there when you went, oh, it was Mimi's film, wasn't it? Where you went from television into film.
Mimi leader. And the other way more recently was the reverse direction was McConaughey and Woody when they went and did True Detective. I remember that was a big shift as well. And so now everything was sort of cross pollinated. Again, I was kind of lucky because it's a really weird thing because, you know, David Caruso quit after one season of NYPD Blue and he, I think he won the Emmy that year. And it was one of those things he went off to do, wanted to do movies and, you know, and said he's leaving. And up until that point, if you wanted to leave your television series
or get out of it or, you know, they didn't let you. I mean, you didn't go. Pierce Brosnan couldn't get out to do Bond early on. And there's tons of stories of, you know, people being sued. And then he left and it sort of kicked the door open. So the next year, ER came out. It was an even bigger hit. And so the first question I was asked every day after the show hit was, you know, are you going to leave the show, which I wasn't. I was like, no, I'm not going to leave. But I wanted to, people were offering me movies and they said, we'll work it out so you can stay on the show and do a movie. So things changed sort of drastically because they were afraid that you would leave the show, which
I had no intention of doing. Was part of the no intention of leaving fueled by a sense of having an ongoing television series is like the greatest warm blanket you could ever have as an actor that you've got a gig at least eight months of the year. And yeah, I mean, how many, like I'd done seven television series before then and 13 pilots. Yeah. And so that's such a famous story that you are that guy who did like all these pilots. So I'm doing a man.
Yeah. I did show Sean. I did a show called Sunset Beat where I played a rock star at night and a cop during the day. Art imitating life. I did some shows. And here, by the way, is there is one of the way who's got the worst show? Let's hear it. Oh, I think I might take the gold on that.
Come on. I did a show that lasted two episodes on NBC with my buddy, Michael Malley called the Michael Malley show. And we were halfway through our seventh episode and they're like, you guys can go home. And we're like, well, we only aired two. And there was it was like literally like a Tuesday and this the morning after the second airing, they were like, we're all done here. So just come get your shit and go to Radford with your tail between your legs and you're back to that line that Warner Brothers auditioning.
Remember? Well, people might not know like the cruelest part of doing and the same listener might know what a pilot is. A pilot is the first episode of a series. And then based on the quality of that episode, the network decides whether there's going to be a following, you know, 21 episodes to make a full season. You know what, Jason? This represents growth for you because rarely do you do that. You take the time to do anything for anybody else. And in that moment to talk, Sean's my sister.
So George, there's a running thing where we explain things for listeners who may not be on the inside. Yes, I've heard. I've heard you explain it. In fact, you're explaining to me now what I actually know. Well, we're going to add you to the runner now. So for George and for Aunt Tracy, sister Tracy. It's sister. It's sister Tracy.
I'm honored. So anyway, so the cruel part is that just to finish my long-winded story, when you go in and you read for a pilot, Tracy, you sign a document that you see on a single page, what your fees are going to be for the next five years with the 5% bumps built in. If you get this job you're about to go audition for in the next 20 seconds. So you actually see, I mean, and you're talking about hundreds of thousands of dollars to somebody who's signing that piece of paper really needs it almost by definition. And it's no leverage.
Like you don't need any more pressure. And there's five other guys signing the same piece of paper. Yeah. It's a lot of work. And you're looking at them like, I could fucking kill this guy. Yeah. If you had to go through that pain repeatedly, George, so that's so, you get on ER and people ask you, you're going to leave a show and they're, fuck no, I'd stay here until they
drag me out. Yeah. I mean, it was, and, and, you know, I remember the first, you know, the show, you know, we were, we were getting like 42 million people to watch the show. That's crazy. And those are numbers, you know, that they're just unheard of when we had 150 channels. Yeah, I remember Noah Wiley saying, is that good? And you go, yeah, that's pretty good.
It's good. I didn't watch ER a lot when it was on first run, but my ex, Amy, whom I think you know, Amy Polar, she is a absolute ER junkie. Really? Oh my God. And so we watched every episode, every night. So I got to know you very well on your ER. My wife is watching them now and it's getting me in a lot of trouble because I've forgotten
all of the, you know, terrible things I was doing, picking up on women and things. Would it be great, would it be great if you started to notice that she started to get just a little bit starstruck around you? Like she didn't know, like, you know, when you work with some people and like you're midway through the production and you happen to watch one of the things that you've never seen that they're really famous for and then you show up to work the next day and this happened really a hundred times and I just like kind of weird around them now. It was sort of like, hey, so I saw such and such last night and oh my God, you were so
good. I get it. Yeah. That's not my wife. Wait, I want to ask you a question about that if it's okay, George, you know, other than the fact that your wife is gorgeous and the most perfect person on the planet, what we're, because I always, you know, we aren't like, we don't hang out every day. Like people probably think we do.
Yeah. They don't. But I always like saw you and I'm like, oh my God, this guy could probably have settled down many, many times. Like other than the fact that Amal is the perfect person for you and your children are perfect and your life is perfect now, what was the, is there reasons behind the 20 year lapse of like, oh, I don't want to go that. I don't want to go that route.
I don't want to get softball. This is a great, this is easy. And by the way, answer that quickly. Right now. What's your answer on that? Just the word. Yes. And you know, the truth was, I met this amazing woman and she took my breath away and she
was brilliant and funny and beautiful and kind and, you know, I sort of swept off my feet. We got engaged after a few months and got married within the first year that we met. That surprised me more than probably anybody else in the world and everybody else was pretty surprised. And now babies, right? What? I got two.
One. How old are they? They're three and a half. They're monsters. Wait, but three and a half. That's such a fun age. Everything gets destroyed in a second. Are you, are you having, because if you're like me, you, you, you discovered the, you
discovered the first 12 months is garbage and then after 12 months, it's the part they all have been talking to you about, like, oh, having kids is the greatest thing in the world. You've only got it after 12 months and then it's just exponentially better and better and better. Well, the first 12 months, the guy has literally no business, right? They don't care about you at all. They're like mom for everything, for food, for everything.
So all you're really doing is cleaning up a lot of shit and feeling sort of useless. And then, yes, the fun starts. My son now, who every mistake he makes as a child is in trying to be funny. So every, like the other day, he literally did the peanut butter joke where he puts it on his shoe and he stands there and he goes, he starts going, pop up, pop up. And he's, I go, yeah. And he goes, you smell poo poo. And I'm like, no.
And I looked down and he looks down at his shoe and he picks up the peanut butter off of his shoe with his finger and then he eats it. Come on. That's pretty high level. And he goes, oh, and I was like, I kind of humor. I loved it. That's great. I was so proud.
Wait, did he pick that up? Do you think from you, or do you have him, because I would learn a lot of humor from watching television and cartoons and stuff. People say, don't let your kids watch TV. No, I taught him that. Yeah. Because that seems like a, that's a George joke right there. Yeah.
I mean, anytime you can use Nutella, peanut butter and a nappy and crunchy, crunchy is sort of adds a little bit of like, oh, Nutella in the nappy and get them to put the nappy like halfway on and then take it off and go to mama and go, mom. And then that's hilarious. That is so on brand from what I've gleaned from you over the years. And I want to get to, because I've told this story a million times and it, and I just retell you telling it. I think I saw you tell it on Carson, I think years ago.
And it was, because you know, you're very close with Richard kind. Yeah. And who's a, who might have had the pleasure. I ran into him last week. Oh, he's. Hello, Jason. Hello, Will. He's such a great guy.
Sean, you were very good, but I was better. The guy is hilarious. I was in the big knife. I killed. But you told me a great story when you guys were roommates, would you please bore these guys? Oh my God. I do.
Please tell the story about the cat. Well, you have to understand. We were sharing. I was living in his apartment, got through a bad breakup and I was living in his apartment and I was an unemployed actor. He was doing the Carol Burnett show, the remake of the Carol Burnett show. And I would watch Jeopardy and you know, there'd be that, you know, Richard loves, he thinks he's a genius at Jeopardy too, as you can imagine.
And so I would watch the East Coast feed and then he would come home and then I would just know all the answers for the West Coast feed and he thought, he's still to this day until he hears this, will have thought that I was the greatest Jeopardy player in the history of Jeopardy. That's fantastic. And it's all horseshit. Richard, if you're listening, fuck you. That's great.
And I would be home and I had nothing to do and he had this little tiny kitten that he would sleep with on his chest and he called a kitty and he'd keep it in the apartment because we're in Hollywood, you know, over on Hayworth and he was working and I'm waiting for an audition and I go into the bathroom and there's a kitty litter box next to the toilet and it's got cat shit in it and I scoop it up and I flush it down the toilet. I'm going, I'm watching Jeopardy, I think, and Richard comes home and he goes to the bathroom, he comes out and he goes, my little kitty has not taken a shit. And I think three days and I don't say anything.
I don't know why. I just don't say anything. I just am like, ah. And the next day the cat takes a shit, I flush it down the toilet, Richard checks and it goes on for like three or four or five days. Meanwhile, you're just trying to be a good roommate, right? I'm just trying to be a friend at this point, you know, and then he takes the cat to the vet and they give him this like kitty metamucil, you know, to clean your colon, you don't understand.
And so now this little kitten is shitting like 15 times a day and I'm scooping, I got nothing to do. I'm reading like hard castle and McCormick auditions, you know, and I've got nothing else to do. I'm flush and Richard's checking, I don't, he flips a cat on its back and he's like, feel his stomach. Does it feel tight to you? And I'm like, that feels kind of tight to me.
Again, I have no idea why it's just funny. And then I scoop up some cats, I don't know, after a couple of weeks and then the light bulb, you know, goes off and I realized what I must do, which is take a shit in the cat box. Now there is this moment, John, when I'm squatted down over a cat box. Really? Yeah. Mom and dad were right.
I should have been a lawyer. Yeah. Exactly. I love the moment that it occurs to you. Oh yeah. You're just like, oh, it's funny. It's good. I'm not sure it's, I want to be remembered, but it's good.
What was the reaction? So I went, you know, and I, when I'm watching Jeopardy, Richard comes home, we're talking for a minute, he goes in the bathroom, he's in there for like a minute and I don't hear anything. And then all of a sudden I hear, oh my God, oh my God, get it. And he comes running out and he goes, you're not going to, you have to come see this. You know, the cat, the cat is like six inches long, I mean, the tiny cat, everything bad about it.
And literally I come in and I just, tears coming down my eyes, I'm laughing to it. And slowly he figures it out and over a whole, it's this long thing where he realizes that I've been shoveling to catch it out and all, and he gets madder and madder and madder. And finally he's like, I understand, Jeopard, defecation doesn't make me laugh. He's just screaming at me. I really respect that kind of commitment to that bit over weeks, the slow burn of it fucking, I get it. Well, I did one where I found a painting that someone threw away, was sitting outside in
the garbage. I took it home, put it in my closet, got some paint, acrylic paint, and painted my name to it. I bought an easel and paints, I set it up in my living room and Richard would come over and go, you want to play golf, I can't, I can't, I got art class. And then I would go to those little, those, those flea markets and I'd buy paintings for like $12, they were good and I'd hang them up on the easel and Richard would come in and go, this is unbelievable.
And the painting I took from the garbage is six feet by three feet of a naked woman. In the worst, it's in aqua and pink, it's the worst painting you've ever seen in life. And after a year of like him, you know, I made him stop at art supply stores with me to feel brushes and palette knives and he kept saying, this is just amazing what you're doing. And he's seen all these other paintings that are pretty decent and he's going, it's really amazing. And finally I go for his 40th birthday, I said, Richard, you've been so supportive.
You know, my art teacher thinks this is the best thing I've ever done and I want you to have it. And it looked great hanging up on your one bedroom wall in the living room and he rips his thing open and he's like, it's great, it's just great. It's beautiful. And I said, it was look good over your couch. And for two years, everyone knew except Richard that I'd taken out of the garbage. So everyone would come into his house and compliment him on his painting and I'm sure
you were there. And just go, it's a great painting. And finally I did, I think the Tonight Show told the story and then said, you know, and I came home and said, Richard, you should, you should watch the Tonight Show and I got the call. I didn't, I, what's wrong with you? That is so funny. And doing the bit like that also telling him through the Tonight Show, then you told the
other one on the Tonight Show. And then didn't you one time, Jillianne Marguerite, didn't you, she asked you for stories and you stole her story and told it the night before she was going to be on, do you remember that? I told, I can't, it was something horrible where I, oh, I told her a story that happened to my mom. Yeah. And then I told her to tell the story and then I had, I had like my mom and her both
telling the story, like in her car back and forth, like tell it as if it's your own. And then they revealed it on the show after she told the story. I think maybe it was Leno and said, yeah, it's funny you should say that because here we have, and they put up the video and you totally set her up. That's so funny. Jillianne had, had my head on a pike for about a year for that one. So I, I learned my lesson on trying to be funny at the expense of your costar. God damn, that makes me laugh.
I want to get back to your life, George, because, okay, it's interesting and I love you and you're fascinating. Go grandma. Good. Here we go. No, I want to know, by the way, sidebar, my sister, I told, and I didn't tell Will and Jason this, I think for every guest that I bring on, like George today, I asked my sister from Wisconsin who we kind of, you know, break things down for so she understands.
I asked her to send in a question for George today and whenever I have somebody, I think that'd be kind of fun. A new element. Sure. My sister Tracy in Wisconsin, she asks, quote, texted this to me yesterday, do it in a Wisconsin accent, please. Okay. Well, it's different than Chicago.
Hey, George. Like, like I want to know what leading lady wasn't in like a joking mood and he got annoyed with them. Maybe they were having an off day and didn't think any of your antics were funny, George. Oh, so she just wants dirt. She wants dirt. You're going to have to apologize for her. Who's grumpy.
She wants to know who's grumpy. No, no. Exactly. All right. We'll skip that. Because, you know, I'm not, I, in general, didn't play horrible pranks on anyone who I was actually going to do a love scene with because that always ends poorly. Yeah.
You know, almost always. Right. Did you ever hear that, that, that saying right before a love scene, I can't remember whose story it is. It's a famous story. And they said to the actress, the guy said to the actress, I apologize if I get hard and I apologize if I don't. Yeah, exactly.
Yeah. I think it was probably like David Niven who always had the great quotes. David Niven at the Oscars when the guy was streaking, do you remember that guy was streaking and Niven just turned to the camera and said, it's amazing that the guys, you know, the greatest moment of this man's life is, you know, by taking off his clothes and showing the world his shortcomings. Just like that. Right.
Like it was like that. Yeah. I was going to streak. I rehearsed it. I was going to streak the year that Franco and Hathaway hosted and I went down and I knew those guys, you know, Bruce Cohn and his partner there were producing. And so I went and I, ABC said, well, you got to wear flash colored underwear if you're going to go across.
And I said, well, I can't. That's not the, then it won't be as funny. I got to go and be, be holding it. Otherwise there's no point doing it. Like then it's just, it's phony. And I wanted to do this bit where I go across, I was going to do this bit where I go across and then try to go up the other side and then slowly creep back and say that the door was locked and sorry about that.
Right. So I rehearsed it. It was great. And, and then ABC was like, and I wasn't wearing underwear and I was just holding all my, all my meats and cheeses and I come, coming across and they go, um, and then ABC was, I see them huddling in the audience and they come up and they're like, yeah, we're not, you're not doing that. I'm like, what?
And they're like, no, we're not running the risk of, no, that's, thank you. You just, do you still get paid? I still got my sag. Yeah, it was great. And I've, I filled some seats on the night and it was great. Yeah. That's good job. Yeah.
The minute someone else wins, you've got to sit right down. I want to ask some more father children questions because that's where you are in your life now. And I think. Yes, I am. So with children in your life who are gorgeous and amazing and obviously with age, a shift comes where, you know, things you deemed important before your priority list completely changes.
So what are some of those things that you kind of pushed down the list after meeting a mom and having a family because, because all we have is time. And so now that's compromised when you are away for four to six months, like you are in Boston right now. Well, my kids and wife are here. Okay. Next question. Yeah.
So that is your question. Next, Tracy. Do you have any more questions? I will say this, you know, there is a funny thing that happens and, you know, I'm late to the game. Tony Randall having children at, you know, 59 and I got three year olds. But it's what everyone else knows, which is that all the things that seemed important aren't, you know, they really aren't.
And it's hard to imagine them not being important before the kids showed up, or before my wife showed up, quite honestly. There was, there was so many other things that I was concerned with that you're concerned with making a living when you first start out as an actor. All you want to do is make a fucking living. You don't want to write weight tables or, you know, sell insurance door to door, which I did. You just want to work and you want to have a living.
And then you want to have some sort of career at some point. And then you want to have some acknowledgement of your work and some, all these things are so important at the time. And then someone like a mall walks into your life, these kids show up magically and everything changes. And all of a sudden, none of that really, you look back and you kind of was such a mad race to, to something that, you know, doesn't give you any of the, you know, it's amazing when things are great, but it comes and goes very quickly.
And, you know, you go home and there's these knuckleheads there and it's changes everything. And do you feel there's pressure about like, you know, they're growing up with you as a father and her as a mother and, and that, that you have a legacy and so how do you handle that? Well, I worry about this. I will say this, you know, all kidding aside, I do worry about the idea, you know, I was friends with Gregory Peck, I was friends with Paul Newman and, you know, they had sons who lost their lives, you know, quite honestly, from trying to live probably under the pressure
of having, you know, someone famous as their father. I think there's an advantage for me, I'm a lot older than they were. My son isn't ever going to feel competitive with me. I'll be gumming my bread by the time they could feel competitive, right? So I think that that's, that kind of goes out the window a little bit, you know, my wife is such an accomplished human being on so many levels and she is so the work she does and how hard she works at it, you know, it'll always be something that will be difficult for either of our kids to live up to is, you know, in a much more important way.
But you know, as you guys do, you have kids, you understand this, it's the same thing. It's our job to make sure that they care about people, that they challenge people in power and look out for people who don't have power. Those are kind of the things I was raised with and believe in. Have you enjoyed what being a husband and being a father has done to your instincts, either premeditated or even on the fly with what you do as an actor or director, your whole sensibility and perception? Let me, let me spin it around.
And to change things for you guys. It did for me. Yeah. I, I, things got, things got more subtle, more sort of surgical and in my, my taste in, in performance, the things I choose to sort of frame up and try to amplify as a director. I just, I'm sort of tuned into a different frequency. I don't know if it's a better one or a worse one, but different things like I cry watching commercials now.
Never used to do that. And there, you know, there's a whole side of me that is much, much softer now. I cry watching Batman and Robin and Jason trust, but it's funny how Jason, he takes that question of like, yeah, and how it applies to him as an actor and a director, not as a human being, like a fucking robot and, you know, because he has, there is no inner life when you scratch the surface, it's more surface, but here I will say this, yeah, it's totally for me, I will say as a human being, thank you, George, talking to another human being, it's completely shifted everything.
Yeah. Like you said, it, it, it, you re-prioritize, it's a brand new perspective, the perspective that I had for leading up to my first son at 38 completely shifted. And what I do, what my priorities are, whatever it is, does it fit my life? And by life, I mean, does it fit my kid's life? And so I find myself, I probably sold myself short a lot professionally because I tried to do everything I could for my kids. And I don't know if that's smart or at the end of the day, somebody's going to say you
should have been more selfish, I don't know. But it's just the way I did it. Here's the funniest part of that. I mean, and I know what you're saying, but there's, I don't think anyone is ever going to say at the end of the day, God, I wish we'd done two more interesting films rather than God, I'm, I'm really glad I spent this time with my kids or did this with my kids or that's, I think the part of the lesson that took me a long time to learn and having children has taught me, which is, and the pandemic is sort of teaching us all too, which
is, you know, we're all learning how deeply connected we need to be and how important it is that we have other things besides our work, because, you know, we know too many people who have been immensely successful in our industry. I mean, all of us have worked with major stars who are no longer stars, you know, shit goes away. Things change. The rules change. But it's, if you have this core, this family, these people that matter to you, then, you
know, you can handle anything. Yeah. Yeah. And I see Jason, all joking aside, I mean, you know, I gave Jason shit the other day, I passed him on sunset, he was dropped and he's driving his Hyundai Palisades, not as a plug, Jason. It's a great car. Great car.
Got a full down seat in the back. And I see him and he's dropping maple off at a friend's house, you know, and like those are the things, we've become, it's so funny, 20 years ago, Jason and I would have been like, look at that clown driving around in the thing ticket. And now we're, I'm passing him and I've just dropped my kids and he's dropping his daughter at the table. That's what I was doing. By the way, when you guys were doing that, I was passing you calling you clowns.
Yeah. Exactly. I was like, look at those fucking clowns. I'm living a life. What are you? Well now I'm literally like behind you cleaning up, you know, shit and washing, you know, everything. I find myself, you know, even whether you have kids or you're just in love, thinking
about mortality more and also getting older. And then, you know, we just had this incident with Tiger in town and it made me think about you, George, about your accent. I've never talked to you about it and I didn't do any reading about it when it did happen aside from like, oh God, I hope he's all right. I didn't want to, you know, comb through it and stuff. But what was, and I don't mean to ask you to tell stories, I'll bet you told a bunch of when it actually happened, but did the Tiger incident bring back some of those memories
for you with respect to your mortality? Now that you've got a family too, that there's an added thing to all of that. You're talking about Tiger Woods accident in his car, like quite a while ago. And George had an accident in Italy, right? I think Tracy saw that in the news. Oh, Sean. Tracy's got that. Yeah, Tracy's got that.
Thanks for specifying which Tiger we're talking about. Well, because we don't know when this is going to air and it's going to be a while later. Right, and another Tiger might become, yeah, famous. Well, look, I will say this. I've been in a couple of funky situations before where I kind of thought it was going to be lights out a couple of times in South Sudan where I thought that, but I didn't have a family and kids and things.
Look, I hit a guy at 70 miles an hour on a motorcycle and I was launched and knocked out of my shoes and hit the ground and I broke his windshield in with my helmet and then went flipping up in the air. And I was fairly sure because I'd been riding for 40 years. I was fairly sure I knew what that meant, which was probably that I broke on my neck. And I read that you landed literally on your knees in your hands or something like that? I land on my hands and knees when I finally hit the ground. You can actually watch it.
There's CCTV footage of it and you can see me going flipping through the air. And it was just luck. If I'd landed on any other direction, I would have been definitely dead. So I remember this about it, which is an interesting thing. I'm a pretty optimistic guy and I actually, I look at the world in a fairly, I always think the best of us. But there was this moment when I hit the ground and Grant, my one of my closest, maybe my closest friend and partner.
The great and creative Grant Hesloff? Yeah, Grant Hesloff. He was in the motorcycle ahead of me and he came running back and he's holding me. I'm only in on the ground and they got glass in my mouth. I thought it was my teeth. It was a windshield glass in my mouth and I really thought this was it. And all the people that got out stood over me. And once they realized it was me, pulled out their cameras and started taking pictures.
And I'll remember that forever because I always think that moment that was probably going to be your last was somebody's entertainment. And it doesn't make me bitter. It just changes my perception of why, is it that important that I have to please everybody? So that thing I'm just going, okay, I get it, fair enough, if that's how it is, I thought it was a little more than that. But you got to take care of you first and foremost at all times. So it's kind of, yeah?
No, not that. I don't think in terms of that. I just think in terms of sometimes we get kind of caught up in the idea that it's more than just entertainment or something like that. The expectation on human beings is lowered a little bit when stuff like that happens. We see it, you see somebody fall in the subway in New York and everybody pulls out their phone. Put your fucking phone down. Yeah.
And lend a hand. Jason and I got in a taxi accident in New York like a year and a half ago on 23rd Street and we got on the side and we're like, geez, and the cab's smoking. We look over and there's a kid right next to us filming us. Really? Yeah. We're like, hey, man. Can you use that phone to call the cops, please?
Yeah. That was the thing. Call the cops. Call the ambulance. I actually told this story. I got hit by a car on 57th Street like four years ago and he was doing at least 40 and I was looking the wrong way and he spun me out and I landed on my feet, but I kind of spun.
I came so close to death because he just caught, he just sort of sideswiped me and I got to the other side and I was so fucking rattled right at Park Avenue and I get over the other side and I'm like, Jesus Christ, I almost fucking died. Look at this guy. He's looking at me and I go, did you see that? And he goes, yeah. Can I get a picture? I went, Jesus, I almost fucking died, asshole.
But you know, George, you bring up something. Did you take the picture though? That's what's important. I did take the picture because he seemed like a genuine fan, but George, I remember one time, I don't know if you remember this. The first time we really met, I was with John Krasinski, we went for sushi and you guys were working on leatherheads at the time and there's a great thing, I gave you a ride back to your house and this struck me and I loved it.
And you're directing a movie and you're George Clooney and you've done all this great stuff and you're doing more great stuff and I was really, I really, and kind of Sean mentioned it before too, you know, you've done, and you talked about it, you've done all these pilots, you know, I did like seven pilots, I had 50 canceled shows, I did every variation that you could of canceled before it went, got fired off a show before it got picked up, like just all of it. And so I always like, in a lot of ways, and I'm almost embarrassed to say this because I hate giving up any power, but you were often in a lot of ways, very much a North Star for
me in a lot of ways. And so it was really cool and we drive back to your house and we get to the gate and I forget what it was, but you, and I'm driving and I said, what's the code? And by the way, the gate looked like it was at a, you know, just at a goat rodeo, it could have fallen off and you could walk around it and you go like, and you go like, it's like one, the code's one, two, three, four, no, you know, what are you out of your mind? And then we drive up to the house and we walk out, we get out and you go, it's okay, door's open.
And I go, and I said to you, I go, are you crazy? You got the fucking world, look at your gate is one, two, three, four, your door's open. You go, yeah, I'm just not going to be a prisoner. Yeah. I'm like, it floored me. It floored me. And also I was like, that's fucking rad. Good for you.
Well, I now have a better code with kids. Yeah, of course, of course, of course, but that was, you know, 15 years ago. And by the way, I don't live there. At the risk of embarrassing you, you really have very consistently sort of represented a way in which to do this, this fame and fortune thing that I think gives actors a good name. I will just say, you have always been so effortless with your, with your just keeping it kind of real. It's never, it's never waned.
Even the responsibility of using your platform to speak up every once in a while about things that you think are left or right of good. And with that specifically, are you, and I don't, I don't want to get you into a political place that you're not comfortable with or any of us are comfortable with in today's, today's climate, but, but given today's climate, do you find yourself thinking twice or three times now before you talk about certain things that might really bug you as opposed to how you may have felt five, 10 years ago? No, I think it's the exact opposite.
You know, I think that, you know, there's a line in the film I wrote, Good Night and Good Luck that Murrow says, because this is no time for, for people who have opinions to be silent. You know, there was a period of time a couple of years ago where the executive branch, the legislative branch and the judicial branch were all kind of dropping the ball in a way. And in some ways, you need the fourth estate to pick up. You need the news organizations and things like that to pick up the slack. And they did.
They did a pretty good job of holding people's feet to the fire, and the judicial branch actually came around eventually. But along those lines, you know, you need people, you got to be out there, if you believe it, you know, and listen, you can be John Boyd and believe that Trump's, you know, a God and save those things, fair enough, you know, have at it, you know, do your thing. But I do believe that this is a time where if you have, you know, I'm not going to lose my right of citizenship because I'm, you know, I've reached a place of success in my career. And you know, I grew up in the 60s, man, you know, we were, if you weren't talking about
social issues, if it was the Vietnam War, the civil rights movement, the women's rights movement or any of those things, you know, there was something wrong with you. And so I grew up with the idea that it's your responsibility to pick fights. You know, what else? What good is this sort of megaphone if you don't get to, you know, try to amplify certain things. And I find it more interesting now. Speaking to that, because you're part of not in our watch project and the tons of foundations
and organizations. Is there one you're most proud of that you pay most attention to that you're most involved? Well, Mal and I have, we have this foundation, the Clinton Foundation, and we're doing some pretty amazing stuff. Like we're right now monitoring the Navalny trial in Russia. It's a fascinating moment. We have trial watchers in about 30 different countries. Countries are using the court system to commit the same crimes that they normally would do
without the court system. So they're basically saying, well, the judge found them guilty when the judge is also the prosecutor. Right, right. And this will be, you know, finding guys guilty for being gay in Nigeria and, you know, all kinds of just insane stuff. So we're putting trial watchers in there. We're trying to, because this is all happening in the darkness.
And so we're trying to be able to set up and create a method and a way to monitor and keep and hold these people responsible. It takes time. You have to build enough cases up to basically create a justice index and where those countries stand on those. Well, that's, that's, that's so rad. And by the way, I just, I just found yesterday, I just found Sean guilty of being gay here in America.
I just can't, I just came out and just got a trial coming up soon. Yeah. Just verdict just came in. What happened to, so do you guys know, I know that publicly they, they say they don't know where Navalny went, but specifically, do you guys have an idea of where he went? Or, and they said, you know, he's not going to be treated any differently. Where he's being captured, man. They're sending him to a work camp now, which is a pretty dangerous spot to go.
But I don't think anyone knows which one. Maybe they do. I haven't, haven't checked. You know, we, we also have one of the parts of our foundation, something that had started before Amal and I actually met was I think called the Sentry. And we're doing with that, you know, the idea of following these, you know, war criminals. I used to do all this stuff. We had a satellite that we rented and we would shine it over the border of the Sudan and
be able to follow troop movements and, and mass graves and, and, you know, we had really really good success at being able to point out these atrocities, but nobody did anything about them. Right. Nothing. You'd have it on the front page of the New York Times and nothing would happen. And we always say these things like never again, but it's always again and always happens. And so what became really clear was you can't make these bad guys be good, but they don't
give a shit. But there's tons of people who are doing business with these bad guys who you can because they want to put on a goddamn tux and go to an award show or go to a banquet because it'll be, you know, for a while, it was the banks who were ignoring these guys who were spending, you know, they're not doing it in Sudanese pounds. They were doing it in pounds and dollars and euros and they're banking in our Western banks. So you go to them and say, well, these guys are laundering about $400 million in your
bank and the banks turned around said, give us all the information. We give it to, you know, to the U.S. government mostly to try and freeze their assets of the Treasury Department. We even did it with the Trump Treasury Department. We gave them tons of information and they froze assets and it's the same thing. So it's really fun to be able to, you know, go to people who really think that they're the good guys and say, well, you're not looking that hard. So we're going to tell you this and I'm going to hold a press conference tomorrow and either
you're going to say, yeah, we have nothing to do with these guys or I'm going to tell them you're complicit and once you do that, you shut down the avenues for these people to spend their money. And that's a big way. You know, we had a good fun time with the salt and the brineye on that as well and it was really effective. That's so right. And on that level, you're not, you're not just using your, your platform and your voice.
You're actually involved in a real way and obviously, you know, follow the money. But by hurting them there, you're really affecting change in a real way. That's super fun. Well, I'll tell you, it's a funny thing. Here's the, here's the deal. All the things we did, we were talking about earlier, whether it makes the cut to your podcast or all the things we were talking about earlier, the pranks that you play, right? The way, when you're playing a prank, you're basically trying to set people up to react
the way you want and to get them to do what you want to fuck with them. Right? Well, that's what you're doing with world leaders in the same way with people who are, you know, war criminals in the same way, you're going, okay, well, I'm going to shed on a paper plate. These exactly show a paper plate and stick it on the thing. But that's the truth because that's sort of the, the, the mentality with this is, yeah, I have a completely different question that we're going to end on and this is from my
brain, George. Okay. If you could, out of the entire cast, if you could have, out of the entire cast of Oceans 11, besides Julia Roberts slept with somebody who would have been, you got Pitt, you got Damon. Please say Brad Pitt. Please say Brad Pitt. Brad Pitt.
This is another one from Tracy. This is Brad Pitt. Yeah. Come on. Yeah. That's a no brainer. Same. Same.
I mean, come on. You guys feel the same. All right. He's pretty, pretty boy Pitt. I'll tell you something. We went to, we went to for Oceans 12, we went to Europe to do the premiere and we ride in, we, you know, Jerry Wine Troubles does everything, so he's got us on a yacht and we're going up to Monaco first on our way to Cannes to open Oceans 12 because Oceans 12 is a perfect Cannes
film. Right? That's exactly what you want to take to Cannes. So we're getting there, we take off and we're in Monaco, there's the Grand Prix. We have our names on the back of a Jaguar race car, right? And while we're riding there, the car rolls over and catches on fire and our names are in flames, you know, above the thing. Oh my God.
We get there and it's Pitt and Cheetle and Damon and I and we're all in this boat and there's surrounded by 50 paparazzi pontoon boats, you know, everywhere just trying to get your picture. And Brad's like, I am going to go up on the top and jump off of this thing. It's like six stories high and we're like, okay, let's do it. We go up there to jump and Brad takes off his shirt and it's like something Michelangelo has carved out of marble, right? It's just like ridiculous.
And then Matt goes, wham! And he pulls off his shirt, which is, yeah, like something that Pillsbury Doughboy cut out of him. And I'm standing there and I'm looking and I go, what's wrong with you, man? I'll take your shirt off right now, you put it on all these people. Unless you wanted a comfortable chest to sleep on, then you go for Matt, you know? It's at the pillow you can punch. You know, Matt will get in like shape.
I mean, he'll be like, you know, Jason Bourne, you know? Off season, you know, it's wine and beer. Let's stay warm. Yeah. It's like. I remember, I was at a Bon Iver concert, Jason, you'll love this, and we were talking to Justin Vernon and we come and Brad came in and he goes, hey, man, I really loved your show that you did for Netflix.
I said, oh, thanks. And we went out the door and I slid down the wall and I cried, oh my God, he's so gorgeous. Now wait a second. If he's validating Bon Iver, I'm in because he did that for me with Radiohead. I had no idea Radiohead was way back when and I still am addicted to Radiohead because he stamped it. You know what? So I'm on Bon Iver now.
I love them. I also said to him, I said, you know, Brad, you know what movie is aged really well? Benjamin Button. That's so dumb. Incredible. Incredible. He liked it. We were shooting, we were shooting Oceans 12 in Italy, Brad, you know, we'd been doing
shit to each other, Frank's to each other. And Brad took out, put posters on telephone poles all around my hometown in Como, Laleo, this little town that said, you know, George Clooney is here shooting now and he only wants to be referred to by his character named Danny Ocean and don't look him in the eye. Just like, in the newspaper, he gets like, il divo. And I'm like, fuck, fuck. I'm like, I'm going to fuck this guy up. And so he had a Prius and I, I, I went to one of those shops that you go to that has
bumper stickers and license plate things and I found a bumper sticker that was in the shape of a pot plant that said, fuck cops. There's no way you don't get pulled over with that on the back of your car. It lasted one day, he came over and he goes, dude, that was, that was cold. Has there been any like garbage about you or fake news about you that has made you laugh? Like, that is so crazy. It always makes us laugh. I mean, I send them to, you know, it's funny because it's, I'm every day, literally every
single day I'll get, you know, life and style or national inquire is going to run this story. You have an hour to respond and it's always just like, you know, it just makes us laugh. I was just right back to like stand my pose and just say, suck it. Because it's just like, you know, what's your response? Suck it. You know, if you're going to be childish, I can be childish. I love it. I don't know.
There's no, the idea that I'd ever see something that even had a grain of truth would be funny. You handle it all with so much grace. You always have, you always will keep leading it for all of us, please. And I know you don't do a lot of press, my friend, and you're very picky. So thank you for being on our dumb dumb show. Well, listen, I want to say this, you guys, and this is absolutely the truth. I have grown this habit of listening to podcasts. I like to listen to them when I get in bed at night.
Some of them I use to help me sleep. Not that that's a bad thing. I'm not talking about yours. I listen to like American history tellers and stuff because I like history ones and I like to learn stuff. And I got turned on to yours a while back and I have to say, I can't play it at night when I want to go to sleep because I sit up and listen to it and laugh through the whole thing. You guys made me laugh.
Well, you made our dough. I've known all of you and I'm a giant fan, but man, you guys together are hysterical. Thank you, George. Thank you, buddy. Likewise, man. It's fun. Really, really appreciate you coming on, man. Yeah, total honor.
It's good to talk to you. Very nice. All right. Enjoy the rest of your day, pal. Okay. Bye, guys. See you soon, buddy. Bye.
See you, George. Sean, what a holy shit. Sean, you got real moves. You know I love George Clooney. Who doesn't? Yeah, it's true. GC in the house. Well, if you had a heads up that it was going to be George, would you, would you have worn
anything different? Would you have done anything different with your hair? Do you think you would have moisturized a little bit more, something like that? Well, why? Do I not look? You look a little dry. Your black shirt is disappearing into your black background there. I feel like you probably would have, you would have gone for something.
By the way, normally I'd hit back with something else, you know, really in trying to take you out. You're still a little stunned. But I'm really, I'm so, I'm so worried and my self-esteem is so shaky around George that that's, so I got to ask you, are you being serious? Because I can't take it. No, I'm not being serious. Because I might cry.
You did very, very well. And so did Sean. We, I think that was awesome. Yeah. I read a lot of stuff that he, there's tons of stuff I wanted to get to that I couldn't, but I, I read a lot of stuff before he came on and he's just, I love that it was like exactly as I, as I, as I, I've always kind of known him to be and I, and I assume our audience always hopes him to be, which is like this perfect balance of funny and smart
and, and, and a listener and a speaker and you know, I mean, it's just, he's, he's, he's he's a perfect man. The other thing that I love, which, and it was kind of, was evident in that story that I told about when I went over to his house with, with Krasinski and we go for, Krasinski goes sushi. I mean, Clooney just texted me, let's go get some sushi. I almost said sushi just texted me. So we go over and then he says, and then George says, Hey, can you give me a ride home?
And I'm like, yeah, no problem. And so I give him a ride home and he was so cool and he was so down to earth and he was so the same. He's the same guy that you see when he's on Carson or, or whatever, or tonight show, or that you see when you meet him 10 years ago, and he's the same guy when you see him and we'd see him. Sometimes he comes, we've seen him over at Jans a couple of times or whatever and just always consistently like, Oh yeah, he's just down to earth and a good guy.
And he spends so much of his free time, not just advocating for people, but actually getting his hands in there and getting his hands dirty and doing it and it's, it's bloody impressive. Isn't it? He walks the walk and talks to talk. Yeah. Yeah. Also, Sean, I like that you brought up. I don't know if it's going to be a normal segment because Jason and I have to talk about
this with the question from Tracy. Isn't that a great idea? And it can only be for my guests, like, right? So you guys don't have to worry about it, but I thought it'd be funny. Just so that I know going forward, is it, is it T-R-A-C-E-Y or just a Y or is it an I? Is it an I dotted with a heart? With a heart?
With a heart is an I? I mean, I don't want to be disrespectful. I just want to know what we're dealing with. Wisconsin, Wisconsin gets a lot. If we do this tour that we've talked about so many times, if we ever do a tour, we'd have to go to Wisconsin. Absolutely. I don't even know if anybody would want to see us on tour.
I'd like to hear from, from Madison to see if they would like to welcome us there. And, and what would be, what would be the other cities? Let's, let's, if any, does he, do people even know how to get a hold of us? Do they vote on cities for a tour? If we get like, like let's say like the five most sort of requests, we'll go to those five cities. Yes. We'll come to your city.
But you got to let us know that you want us first because we're really insecure. You need to go first and invite us instead of us assuming you want to see us. Tell us why you, not why you're worthy, but why we're worthy of coming to your city. I love that. It's a great idea. Guys, this has been a, a, a, an embarrassment of riches as far as ideas going today. Today. Today's episode has a lot of God.
And if we do a tour also, can we stay with you? Yeah. Let us know. That's a deal breaker. Do you have like a guest house or is it a, is it a blow up? We'll need pictures. So. Yeah.
We'll probably need pictures. And then we'd also need to be able to send stuff that we like, like I like half and half just to make sure. Probably a car. Right. Use of a car. A car for, which is fine. We could share, um, but we're coming to your town and we're coming to your house.
We're coming to your house. Let us know if you want us there and we'll, the house that we send out everything and, and we'll, we'll be there. Also should we do a tour at all? Should actually for real, should we do a tour? I think we should. I think it'd be fun. I don't know.
People would want us. I'm available. Let's see. I'd like to finally see you guys while we're talking to each other. Yeah. Right. That would be actually, you know, a lot of podcasts do, do tours. Is that right?
Yeah. Well, why not us? Let's, uh, let's put it in the pipe and smoke it. Okay. Well, we'll see people. Maybe they don't want it. People are like, then we don't want to see you. Okay.
Um, all right. Well, um, so, uh, there's a bunch of different kinds of bicycles, right? There's the, the one with the three wheel and what's the one with the two wheels called? Um, bye. So, uh, uh, all right. Oh, yeah. Bye. Bye.
Bye. Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Bye! Oh, so stupid. Smart.
Right. Smart. Right. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.